[Musique]
je m'appelle à 106 morts et j'ai 10 ans
passionné de lecture je raconte des
histoires depuis mon plus jeune âge
avant la maternelle je savais déjà mon
alphabet et depuis j'écris des livres et
des victoires mais détrompez vous ce
n'est pas ma seule passion depuis l'âge
des caprins le scar occupe une place
importante dans ma vie
lors de cette présentation je vous
parlerai de la réussite scolaire car
malgré les difficultés
tout est possible pour y arriver
j'appuierai mes propos allied exemples
de personnages bien connus du monde
entier motivation persévérance volonté
acharnement et patients sont des
qualités importantes pour réussir à
l'école
supposons que je vous dis qu'un garçon a
passé tout son parcours scolaire à
s'amuser sans n'ai jamais étudié il
était premier de sa classe chaque année
me croyez vous si c'est possible
il est une des rares exceptions car
habituellement honda mais des efforts
dans tout si on veut réussir c'est très
important et c'est justement de cela que
je vienne me parler car en travaillant
fort de la réussite devient possible
pour tout le monde j'imagine que tout le
monde ici connaît albert einstein le
grand génie qui a inventé la théorie de
la relativité un des formules des plus
révolutionnaires mais connaissez vous
réellement son histoire ce sévère des
génies il en a surmonté des obstacles
beaucoup plus que vous ne le croyez
il a d'abord débuté son primaire avec un
retard de la parole et de la lecture
il avait beaucoup de difficultés dans
les matières mais particulièrement en
mathématiques
par la suite il fut renvoyé du primaire
quelques années plus tard il fut même
refusé à l'école polytechnique et
soupçonnait être arriéré mental
loin d'abdiquer à cette situation celui
ci persiste à jusqu'à obtenir le prix
nobel et changer le visage de la
physique moderne
ma vie a été difficile et il mais c'est
normal car la vie est comme une
bicyclette et il faut avancer pour ne
pas perdre l'équilibré
bien que différente l'histoire de marie
curie célèbre fils
les chimistes fut remplie d'obstacles
elle aussi à l'âge de 9 ans elle par sa
soeur de fja du typhus et à 11 ans sa
mère de la tuberculose de graves
maladies
après le décès de sa mère elle décide de
noyer sa peine dans les études pour les
quais développant une véritable passion
elle voulu faire des études supérieures
mais celle ci est interdite aux femmes
dans son pays
plutôt que de baisser les bras elle se
trouva un emploi et à massat les fonds
nécessaires pour réaliser son rêve
c'est donc à paris qui a obtenu son
diplôme
par la suite elle fut la première femme
à obtenir le prix nobel deux fois une
fois pour la physique et une autre pour
la chimie voilà ici un très bon exemple
de persévérance
la clé de la réussite ce n'est pas le
succès est encore moins l'intelligence
c'est la ténacité un mélange de
persévérance et de passion on doit pas
avoir peur d'essayer de nouvelles choses
car oui il est possible que parfois l'on
se perde
mais ce n'est pas ça l'important
l'important c'est de se dépasser chaque
fois et de ressortir de tous a grandi en
conclusion ce n'est pas le nombre
d'obstacles qui importe mais plutôt la
façon de les surmonter
car chaque erreur ouvre une voie vers le
futur albert einstein et marie curie
sont deux exemples de la cité
remarquable il ya beaucoup d'obstacles
dans la vie mais les plus grandes
barrières sont celles que l'on s'impose
car en travaillant fort la réussite
devient possible pour tout le monde il
n'oubliait pas on peut tout changer avec
de l'effort on doit tout essayé mais on
doit être prêt a échoué avoir tort et a
recommencé en apprenant de nos erreurs
car c'est lorsque l'on se perd que le
voyage commence vraiment merci
[Applaudissements]